no one thought sam walton would live an
extraordinary life he worked in a jc
penney's and waited tables for most of
his teens in early 20s when he got
married he saved up some money and
borrowed some money from his
father-in-law to buy a branch of the ben
franklin stores owned by the butler
brothers it seemed like a typical white
pick offense american dream except for
one thing sam walton loved information
specifically he loved information on how
other stores were making more money than
he was in his first year of owning his
store he visited every single other
grocery and retail shop in bentonville
arkansas he observed every single thing
they did how they display their goods
what discounts they offered the prices
he would have to beat and even how the
shop was set up
he would stay in the store so long the
shop owners would get genuinely creeped
out he didn't care though the
information he collected on how other
shops ran helped him come up with a
strategy to completely destroy his
competitors he saw that every single
competitor thought small short term make
a lot of profit off of a single product
so they wouldn't have to make too many
sales so he decided to think long term
and focus on tiny margins and a lot of
sales that way he would be able to make
his prices so much lower than any of his
competitors that they could never even
dream of matching them thus wiping them
out
if other competitors sell toothpaste for
two dollars and made a one dollar
profits he would sell toothpaste for one
dollar and fifty cents sure he would be
making less money in the short run but
in the long run he would steal all of
his competitors customers away from them
thus all their profits would flow to him
anyways
his only real problem was that the
franchise store he had bought wouldn't
let him go to such extremes
for his first few years only a few
products were allowed to be discounted
and that didn't sit well with sam walton
so he stayed up again and in 1962 he
opened up the very first walmart
discount city store in rogers arkansas
now he had the power to do as much
discounting as he likes and thus the
start of a new american dynasty was born
[Music]
my ache and back i've been to so many
stores shopping the walmart way i'm back
so soon i got everything i need at
walmart that's the idea shopping the
walmart way makes savings simple and
convenient everything at walmart is
always at a great price
[Music]
walmart super inflation buster sale
blasts through the inflation barrier
with big discount savings on hundreds of
everyday items like conair's lots of
curls curling iron now just 3.93 renews
at 6 ounce air freshener only 31 cents
kleenex tissue discount price to just 48
cents colgate nine ounce toothpaste only
one dollar and cordite heavy gauge 26
gallon trash can liners just 96 cents
for the 20 count box for super inflation
buster savings on hundreds of items shop
walmart now through saturday
in 1969 walmart was incorporated and
within just 11 years there were more
than 270 walmarts across america sam
walton had discovered a simple yet
overlooked universal truth people loved
discounts above all else in small towns
your early targets you would move in and
every other retail or grocery store in
the area would have to shut down there
was no way they could compete with your
prices even if they sold their goods at
cost they still couldn't even come close
to walmarts because of the power of the
economies of scale if a family owned
retail shop bought a hundred t-shirts
for five dollars each they could sell it
for six dollars in their store and make
a one dollar profit but because of
walmart's size they could buy a hundred
thousand t-shirts negotiate the price
down to three dollars and fifty cents
each from the supplier and then resell
those shirts for four dollars and ninety
five cents you're able to beat your
competitors price by more than a dollar
while making even more profits and even
if the family owned store dropped their
price to five dollars so they wouldn't
be making any money their prices would
still be more expensive that was the
beauty of discounting walmart got so
famous for putting competitors out of
business it earned a nickname the
walmart effect whenever a walmart moved
into town all the small retail
competitors would have to close and you
would basically have a monopoly over the
retail industry in that town it got so
bad that people started accusing walmart
of predatory pricing making prices so
low that you knew your competitors were
closed down well they weren't entirely
wrong destroying his competition was
after all sam walton's only goal
11 years into business and walmart
breaks a billion dollars in sales seven
years later that number 15x to 15
billion dollars by the year 2020 walmart
was at the top of the fortune 500 list
since then walmart has been consistently
been either the first or second largest
company by revenue in the world but
discounting was only part of the makings
of this empire to get to the top walmart
would have to step on a lot more shoes
than just the small businesses that shut
down
walmart made money in retail but today
one of the most trending ways to make
money is by trading nfts where people
are making life-changing money just from
getting in on an nft hype early on
buying and then selling soon after for
insane amounts of money and one way to
do that is to look at what crypto whales
are buying crypto whales are influential
people who have a ton of crypto so if
they buy an nft project others tend to
follow pushing the price up the hard
part is catching on to these crypto
whale hype trains early on so you're not
left holding the bag are most of these
nfts useless absolutely but that doesn't
mean you can't make money off of them
that's where project metamux comes in
and this is free by the way so you're
going to want to stick around metamux is
a tight-knit community tailored made for
beginners who are looking to make money
in the nft space and within their
discord they have what's called their
whalebot tracker a tool that monitors
the wallets of crypto whales and sends
you a discord alert every single time
they buy on nft projects once you get
alerted you can check out the nft
project they bought buy it yourself if
you want and sell at a hopefully higher
price and the best part is that this
discord is 100 free right now with the
link below the catch is that when their
metamox nft project launches the
whalebot and the other tools and
resources in the discord will only be
available to the holders of the nft
which has a very low supply of only four
thousand four hundred forty four mega
months so you're gonna want to get in
while you can for free they're also
doing a giveaway for a hundred whitelist
spots within their discord they plan to
mid this january all you gotta do is
join the men and mugs discord for free
by going to jake.yt metamonks with the
link below it literally costs zero
dollars and you have zero obligation to
buy anything this link will take you to
their twitter where you can follow them
and then join the discord with the link
in their twitter bio again that's
jake.yt menomons with the link below
thanks to menomox for sponsoring this
video
stocking is one of my
things i like to do here at walmart
i like to organize things so they look
perfect
i have a system which just basically is
i do everything one step at a time it's
like building a pyramid looks neat
people like attractive things and you
know eventually you get your finished
product
everyday low prices keep our associates
busy all year
the holidays mean they'll just be a
little busier
in the 70s workers at walmart were
thinking about unionizing or joining
forces as workers to use their strength
in numbers to get their employer to
negotiate better working conditions for
them that didn't last long as soon as
walmart learned about the potential
union they hired a union busting
consultant to come up with a strategy to
bust up potential unions here's how it
works whenever a walmart store or a
distribution center would try to
unionize walmart would simply use
intimidation tactics to scare workers
into not voting for unionization if they
voted to unionize they would be fired if
intimidation tactics were an option or
didn't work and workers still voted to
unionize walmart was simply announced
that they would be shutting down the
place under the excuse that it just
wasn't profitable anymore which honestly
could have been true if the law
prevented them for shutting the place
down they would just flat out refuse to
negotiate with the unions there's even
an informative book called the manager's
toolbox for remaining union free hidden
cameras have been installed in parking
lots break rooms and offices all to
monitor for any potential union talk if
anyone breathes the word union they are
out this allows for some neat tricks you
can play on your workers
fall is almost here and at your red deer
walmart we welcome autumn with special
savings throughout the store
you'll find low prices in every
department from sporting goods to car
care
products to clothing
and electronics
you'll save big this fall on quality
items for the entire family
we'll help you find everything you're
looking for
walmart has over 2.3 million employees
having that many employees means there's
a lot of room for losing money if an
employee costs you just an extra dollar
a day that's 2.3 million dollars going
down the drain every single day or
nearly a billion dollars wasted every
year that's why walmart's minimum wage
is 12 dollars an hour whereas amazon has
a minimum wage of 15
but that's probably just one of amazon's
tactics for driving out competitors that
we've covered before so as walmart you
gotta be extremely diligent when it
comes to cutting costs and one of those
areas of focus is overtime pay
understaff your stores on purpose that
way it forces other employees to work
overtime to pick up the slack for
departments that didn't have enough
people i knew that we were short staffed
at that time i didn't know it was a
purposeful thing that um that's their
intention they had stacks like this of
applications in the back they just
didn't hire them right and then we're
told we don't know what to do we don't
have the people we don't have this we
don't have that and and i really did it
first i i was really i felt bad for them
it was like oh okay
i'll give you an extra hour here i'll
give you i'll come in early tomorrow
okay i won't take my day off and when
they work overtime you would just make
sure the extra hours were moved on to
next week so they didn't count as extra
no seriously some walmart managers have
actually been taught how to log into
computers with a fake user id to move
extra work hours to the next we said
they wouldn't count as overtime he
explained to us how to go in the system
under a false user id to get into the
computer and move that time to the next
week i've seen managers go in when
someone worked
41 42 hours
and change it to 40 hours keep medical
coverage minimum to the point where most
employees have to join state-funded
programs that means less money coming
out of your pocket and more money coming
out of the state taxpayers pockets and
it's not just medical aid food stamps
daycare and education for associates all
come out of taxpayers pockets
but they're a billion dollar corporation
so i don't see why they cannot offer a
better medical package for their
associates so that we can't afford to
get our families on
insurance so your dignity is not there
your pride is not there you go to work
knowing that you're not making enough
money to really make ends meet but yet
you gotta go with a smile on your face
and and fake it
yeah that's pretty bad all these less
than ideal conditions help you save
money but it also comes with one added
benefits quick employee turnaround
around 70 of walmart employees leave
within their first year now this might
sound bad but in reality it's a blessing
in disguise
employees that don't stick around means
that they won't ask for raises or
promotions you can just keep paying them
low wages because most of your employees
are new and that's the expectation with
a new job and being that walmart shuts
down most of the other retail jobs in
the area walmart along with other big
chains usually becomes the only options
available for a low-skilled job and
overseas it's an even dire story
bob you're restocking housewares
surely you're on register eight you in
the yellow
you know what to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're rolling back prizes all over the
store to save you even more always low
prices always walmart
remember the bangladesh factory fire in
2012
no well a clothing factory caught fire
and 112 workers died survivors said
there were no fire extinguishers and the
doors were locked when they tried to
escape as it turns out this was one of
the very factories walmart used to
manufacture their low cost clothing at
first walmart tried to deny it but then
pictures of walmart's clothes and
walmart labels
lying around out from the fire made that
denial a little hard to believe in most
cases these workers earn less than 15
cents per hour making products for
walmart and this is just a tiny sliver
of all the labor controversies walmart
has gotten itself into child labor
exploiting undocumented workers
everything is fair game
the worker is given a fake pay slip and
they never let you have the chance to
speak out the truth but threaten you to
deliver false information
we really work day and night in order to
get the wage of less than three dollars
a day
my mom wants me back home because she
feels it's too toilsome
[Music]
[Music]
even after all the scandals walmart is
still the biggest company in the world
by revenue in 2020 walmart made over
half a trillion dollars in sales that's
around 1.5 million dollars in profit
every single hour in 2021 walmart has
over 10 000 stores in 24 countries and
most of it is still owned by the walton
dynasty proving that the general public
is willing to turn a blind eye to
anything for their own personal gain
even if it's just a tiny discount
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you